[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 de l'actualité des idées de
sorties est pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 26 novembre
face à la cinquième vague de coded 19
les annonces du gouvernement tous les
plus de 18 ans sont désormais invités à
effectuer une troisième dose de vaccin
cinq mois après leur dernière injection
sans quoi leur pass sanitaire serait
désactivé entre précipitation pour
prendre un rendez-vous et inquiétude les
réactions à suivre un nouveau président
pour la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines guillaume
cairou a été élu cette semaine pour un
mandat de cinq ans il succède à gérard
bacheliers à la tête de la cci 78
pendant huit ans et guillaume cairou est
notre invité
et puis comme chaque vendredi notre
sélection d'idées pour sortir dans le
département c'est dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission et c'est avec
bien sûr bixente mais rien senti steban
bonjour bixente janvier goren quel est
le programme du jour aujourd'hui on va
parler magie on va parler star wars mais
aussi de football par exemple encore je
me prenais par les sentiments
aujourd'hui bixente et ce sera tout à
l'heure dans le sais tu ce week-end
il ya l'actualité d'abord un taux
d'incidence qui est repassé au dessus
des 200 dans les yvelines l'épidémie de
covin 19 est en forte hausse partout en
france pour contrer la cinquième vague
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
s'est exprimé ce jeudi à retenir dans
les annonces l'ouverture dès samedi de
la campagne de rappel du vaccin point
tous les adultes de plus de 18 ans de 18
ans et plus sous les recommandations de
la haute autorité de santé cette
troisième dose et a effectué cinq mois
après la dernière injection dès le 15
janvier d'ailleurs le pass sanitaire
sera désactivée si la dose de rappel n'a
pas été réalisé dans un délai de sept
mois après la dernière injection
conséquence d annonce le site d'octo
l'ibpt a été vite saturé ce jeudi est la
plate forme pour prendre des rendez-vous
de vaccination a connu une fréquentation
record 1 million de rendez-vous
enregistré en une journée entre
précipitation pour trouver un créneau et
inquiétude écoutez les quelques
réactions de ces yvelinois collectées
par mathilde franco dans une pharmacie
du département uma script pour avoir un
rendez vous pour la troisième dose
contre le candidat j'aurais aimé que ce
soit avant les fêtes mais
malheureusement ce sera pour le 4
janvier je suis soignante donc je suis
obligé
oui je vais le faire j'ai commencé la
regarder ouais c'est un peu compliqué au
niveau des places mais je suis en repos
cette semaine qu'il faut que je le fasse
je suis encore dans les délais parce que
c'est six mois par rapport aux passes
mais je vais le faire je sais que gérer
ou vaccinodromes de saint-quentin s'il
n'est pas fermée j'ai vu que on va
devoir se vacciner si l'on passe
sanitaire sera plus disponible et donc
je pense que je me vaccine ray j'aurais
pas le choix parce que pour ça pour
faire des sauts retirer pour faire des
sorties avec les amis ce sera nécessaire
ils commencent à fermer les centres de
vaccination donc ça devient plus
compliqué de ça va être compliqué après
pour se vacciner et avec des centres de
vaccination qui ont fermé leurs portes
d'autres qui ont réduit la voilure
difficile de s'organiser pour injecter
une troisième dose de vaccin à tous les
adultes de plus de 18 ans ce pharmacien
ce formation est également acquis à
écouter l'aller vaccinodromes sont 1
ce moins performants enfin moins de
capacités de vaccination que
qu'auparavant donc le relais doit être
pris par les par les professionnels de
santé libéraux médecins pharmaciens
notamment
sauf que pour l'instant on n'était pas
en mesure de faire face à cet afflux de
personnes donc on essaie de s'organiser
différemment déjà là notre capacité
était saturé on est passé de 2 20 25
vaccination semaine à une soixantaine sa
demande des ressources humaines
supplémentaires c'est compliqué en ce
moment parce que les équipes sont déjà
fatigués épuisés de deux années de
communes et parmi les autres annonces à
retenir pour les personnes non vaccinées
le délai de validité des tests liés aux
passes sanitaire est réduit à 24 heures
masque obligatoire de nouveau dans les
lieux fermés plus de fermeture
systématique des classes dès le premier
cas positif en école primaire enfin la
vaccination des 5 11 ans est envisagée
mais pas avant 2022
les soixante quinze mille entreprises
des yvelines ont leurs nouveaux
représentants cette semaine la nouvelle
assemblée de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines a été installé
par le préfet du département 30 membres
et un nouveau président il est avec toi
en plateau c'est guillaume cairou
bonjour bonjour oui oui bonjour
effectivement diffuser à 18h alors vous
êtes le dirigeant le fondateur également
de didaxis et vous avez été élu à
l'unanimité à la tête de la cci 60,18
votre liste d'union medef ces pme et
indépendants conduite également avec
magali carré il y aurait je sais pas si
je prononce bien c'est ça a remporté les
élections consulaires qui se déroulait
du 27 octobre au 9 novembre et vous
débutez donc un mandat de cinq ans dans
quel état d'esprit vous l'aborder dans
ce contexte on le sait particuliers
aussi bien sur le plan économique et
avec un contexte sanitaire toujours
incertain aujourd'hui un contexte serein
et optimiste puisque en fait
effectivement tout terrain réinventer
dans le territoire avec cette pandémie
la façon dont on va se déplacer la façon
dont on va travailler la façon dont on
va s'alimenter dont on a soigné des
entreprises vont effectivement
disparaître mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que de très nombreuses entreprises
on a un soutien et c'est le rôle
principal de la chambre de commerce un
soutien important qui a été mise en
place pendant toute la pandémie
notamment à travers le dispositif rosso
qui était
à l'initiative de gérard bacheliers le
l'ancien président et je tiens à saluer
son travail à travers effectivement la
dynamisation des commerces de proximité
avec le club commerce de la mise en
place effectivement de projets
touristiques autour du projet spot a mal
on voit là c'est tous ces sujets
tourisme commerces de proximité
réindustrialisation soutien au chef
d'entreprise dans cette période
difficile puisque les prêts garantis par
l'état vous de voir bientôt être
remboursés donc il va falloir vraiment
soutenir ces chefs d'entreprise orthez
d'un an mais là rien les chefs
d'entreprise c'est vraiment la dynamique
de cette nouvelle assemblée avec un
jeune président qui voilà qui avec le
qui est soutenu je suis soutenu par 30
candidats avec quinze femmes qui ont été
élues 15 am c'est une saison
complètement unie nouveaux membres sont
uniques en france c'est unique en france
rock le 23 des nouveaux élus sont des
élus sont des nouveaux la plupart sont
des sondés nouveaux membres certains
étaient associés et surtout nous
représentons tous les secteurs
d'activité du département de
l'aéronautique au commerce de proximité
en passant par l'industrie textile par
les métiers liés à l'artisanat
car on a effectivement 75 mille
entreprises du ressort de la chambre de
commerce qu'on est aussi incertain
d'artisans il va falloir je pense
accompagner tous les chefs d'entreprises
y compris ceux qui ont une activité
agricole on a avec cette transition
écologique la volonté vraiment de de
verdir un petit peu notre économie et
donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment des
sujets entre les différentes chambres
consulaires que ce soit la chambre de
commerce d'industrie la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat et la chambre
d'agriculture vraiment une dynamique
vraiment très très optimiste pour tous
ceux qui dans notre département cherche
à
participer à ce nouvel élan à créer leur
propre activité et la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie sera toujours là
à leurs côtés pour les accompagner à
toutes les étapes de leur
de leurs activités vous l'avez dit vous
succéder à gérard bacheliers 17 ans à la
cci des élus huit ans comme président
dont vous allez être dans la continuité
tout en insufflant aussi quelques
nouvelles dynamiques c'est ça votre suis
je m'inscris vraiment dans la continuité
du du fabuleux travail qui a été fait
par par hager à mâcher lier les on l'a
vu sur le terrain les entrepreneurs ont
besoin d'accompagnement d'un autre côté
il se demande souvent ce à quoi servent
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
mais il ya un sujet très fort et sur
lequel on va devoir être très très bon
c'est la formation professionnelle
puisque la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie gère près de neuf campus
dans les yvelines qui vont du ceap et
dans tous les métiers qu'on ne trouve
plus dans le département des métiers
manuels on a besoin de fraser on
visitait ce matin une entreprise de
mécanique de précision à guyancourt donc
il faut voilà il faut valoriser tous ces
métiers dont on aux entreprises ont
besoin dans le territoire puisqu'ils on
a un problème de pénurie en terme de
matière de main d'oeuvre va falloir les
accompagner les formes et les former aux
métiers de demain et les métiers de
demain souvent sont un peu les métiers
d'hier donc il va falloir fall a créé
une un bon projet de formation qui va
permettre de s'adapter aux besoins du
marché si on vient sur votre parcours
vous êtes originaire de mantes la jolie
vous avez d'abord été éducateur
socioculturel puis consultant spécialisé
dans les projets de transformation
d'entreprises et d'administrations et je
le dis en 2004 vous avez fondé l didaxis
qui est l'un des leaders mondiaux
aujourd'hui du portage salarial vous
êtes à la tête de cette entreprise de
700 salariés en quoi justement cette
expérience va vous aider dans vos
nouvelles fonctions maman fait je me
suis à la base je suis effectivement
éducateurs et enseignants dont je suis
fonctionnaire à la base donc j'étais pas
du tout je suis pas née entrepreneurs
donc c'est aussi dire et puis je suis né
dans un milieu ouvrier dans un quartier
prioritaire de la ville à
mantes-la-jolie comme vous l'avez dit
donc c'est aussi le signal à tous nos
jeunes qui nous écoutent qui ne trouvent
pas de deux voies à travers leurs
trajectoires professionnelles de savoir
que l'entreprise est un véritable
ascenseur social que ça fonctionne et
c'est et c'est vraiment ce message là
que j'ai envie de passer à tous les
yvelinois et qu'ils soient jeunes et
moins jeunes parce qu'on a aussi le
chômage des seniors il va falloir
vraiment qu'on soit tous unis tous
ensemble collectivement pour accompagner
ce nouvel élan dans notre territoire
puisque il faut savoir 25 % des emplois
de 2030 donc c'est demain seront
indépendants donc comment on fait pour
accompagner tous ces néo entrepreneurs
voilà c'est le projet de mon équipe il
nous reste 30 secondes vos premières
priorités vous le disais tout à l'heure
le volet industriel de ce département le
sait la vallée de seine saint quentin en
yvelines un fort potentiel industriel
également on peut être re dynamiser le
tourisme l'accompagnement voilà
l'accompagnement industriel et surtout
la proximité la revitalisation des
coeurs de villes à travers ces commerces
de proximité vraiment le soutien la
proximité les talents et puis surtout
les territoires avec l'accompagnement de
la ruralité merci à guillaume qui est
heureuse d'être venue en plateau et je
le rappelle nouveau président de la cci
versailles yvelines la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans l'actualité
également la visite d'amélie de
montchalin ce vendredi dans les yvelines
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique était à houilles
dans la matinée l'occasion d'échanger
avec des apprentis en formation petite
enfance dans la commune entre 2016 et
2021 le nombre d'apprentis accueillis
dans la fonction publique a presque
doublé passant de 13 milles à 24 milles
que faut-il retenir de l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines matip de
franck où vous résume le tout en 78
secondes
les restos du coeur ont lancé leur 37e
campagne d'hiver dead alimentaire avec
la crise sanitaire et la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat de nouvelles personnes
sont venues au centre de distribution de
plaisir celui ci observe une
augmentation de 40 % des bénéficiaires
treize militants appartenant au
mouvement d'ultra droite recolonisation
france ont été interpellés l'un des
membres est un colonel de gendarmerie en
poste dans les yvelines lors des
perquisitions une cinquantaine d'armes
des gilets pare balles et un exemplaire
de mein kampf ont été trouvés
karim benzema reconnu coupable de
complicité et de tentative de chantage
dans la sphère de la sextape de mathieu
valbuena l'attaquant du real madrid est
condamné à un an de prison avec sursis
et 75000 euros d'amendé un jugement
rendu par le tribunal correctionnel de
versailles
cette jeune monté ombé d'aller en
direction de montpellier pour soutenir
les femmes victimes de violence leur
périple mis en images lors d'un
documentaire a permis de récolter 1600
euros pour le centre d'information sur
les droits des femmes et des familles
des yvelines
et enfin la collecte dix centres
pédiatriques des côtes situées aux loges
en josas officiellement lancée retenu
pour le loto du patrimoine le site du
19e siècle doit être rénové
allez maintenant c'est l'heure de sortir
dans les yvelines
avec bien entendu la sélection de
bixente mais rien senti stevan qui est
revenu en plateau et pour commencer vous
nous faites rentrer dans le moule de la
grande illusion bixente grégory avec un
festival qui va se dérouler tout le week
end ça commence samedi à 14h30 un
festival de magie donc le premier
spectacle qui s'appelle le fantôme du
pirate puis à 16 heures un atelier de
magie pour les petits et les grands et à
partir de 20 heures la grande soirée des
buts nadia el meliani organisatrice du
festival vous en dit plus le soir on va
être dans une ambiance cabaret avec du
close-up d'abord et ensuite
et ensuite le cabaret de la grande
illusion
charlie le champion de france de 2016
sera par nino est donc ce sera génial ça
termine donc dimanche par un spectacle
familial à 15h30 et pour le casting de
nombreux magicien seront présents
d'indian meliani l'a mentionné charlie
champion de france de magie en 2016 mais
pas qu'eux ils viennent il vient avec
ses acolytes magicien illusionniste nous
avons rencontré l'un d'eux philippe d
avoir une vraie salle de spectacle avec
entre ami magicien et puis vraiment
accueillir bien les les spectateurs leur
faire un grand spectacle ça c'est
quelque chose qui nous tient vraiment à
coeur a vraiment un gros plateau
d'artistes avec énormément de moyens
techniques sas et c'est quelque chose
qui y verront une fois deux fois dans
leur vie quoi vous n'allez pas vous
improvisez magicien bixente même si
chaque chaque semaine vous nous sortez
de votre chapeau beaucoup d'idées de
sorties pour sortir de balayer de sortie
pour sortir forcément dans les yvelines
en tout cas philippe philippe day 1c ça
vous a donné un avant goût de ce qui
allait se passer oui un tout petit
grégory le jour j il y aura bien entendu
beaucoup plus de moyens mise en oeuvre
c'est un peu le grand cabaret version
opéré en yvelines mais c'est vrai que
philippe m'a fait un petit tour de passe
passe avec un billet de 5 euros regardez
donc en fait c'est une histoire
d'origami c'est l'art du pliage japonais
alors les japonais font des petits
oiseaux des petites fleurs des trucs
très très mignon mais bon moi je préfère
faire des billets de 500 et je trouve ça
vachement plus sympa alors tous explique
le principe faut bien faire les plis au
départ ensuite vous avez de la gauche
vers la droite après du bas vers le haut
encore de la gauche vers la droite après
on fait ce qu'on appelle la bascule vous
prenez le billet vous payez vous leur
déplier et vous obtenez un billet 2 500
ha dont nadia tu ne te réjouis pas trop
vite parce qu'en fait c'est 500 $
caribéen donc ça vaut pas 5 euro jettent
rembourser je te laisse le billet de 500
je vais te faire un avoir magique c'est
magique et on sait à boire autant il
faut que je trouve un papier pour faire
un avoir c'est pour toi
je te rends mon billet et les cinq sens
et pour toi
mais je t'en prie pour venir voir le
reste de l'événement tout ce qui vous
attend ça se passe dans la salle des
fêtes de la mare aux loups opéré en
yvelines appelé directement nadia el
milia ni pour réserver donc au 06 77 57
65 50 les tarifs varient selon ce que
vous voulez faire en fait le temps que
voulait rester si vous voulez assister
au cabaret par exemple du samedi soir
c'est 20 euros et pour tout le week-end
donc samedi et dimanche c'est 40 euros
place à présent bixente à votre invité
du jour avec une exposition inspirée du
sel d'une célèbre saga par delà les
étoiles oui voisin contre attaque
grégory c'est le nom de l'exposition
lancée dès demain samedi 27 novembre à
la maison de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour nous en
parler nous recevons johan schelin
médiateur culturel de voisins par
visioconférence bonjour bonjour yoann
dans l'exposition on retrouve donc
beaucoup de choses des constructions en
jeu de briques des photographies des
jeux vidéo et autres produits dérivés de
la célèbre saga pourquoi avoir décidé de
nous plonger à voisins dans l'univers
star wars qu'est ce qui a inspiré cette
exposition en fait les books tous les
ans on fait des expositions thématiques
art voisin est ce que c'est beaucoup
quelque chose qu'on fait nos règles et
nos partenaires qu'ils soient
associatifs ou des entreprises et comme
c'est des gens qu'on voit souvent c'est
vraiment venu à la suite de l'exposition
jeux vidéo il ya maintenant trois ans en
2018 baron n'était que certains
partenaires on faisait pas ce serait
bien de continuer dans la pop culture
dans un univers à la fois il ya des
choses à apprendre du culturel et iard
avec mira côté très très ludique et très
pédagogique qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire et on s'est dit à 100 m pages
sympa de faire de faire une expo sur
star wars et ça a vraiment commencé
comme ça le point de départ c'était ça
dans le programme du coup bien que la
salle de la tour n'est pas pu ouvrir
plusieurs animations sont prévues durant
ce week-end le week-end de lancement je
pense notamment à samedi à 15 heures
avec ce que vous appelez les récrés
artistes sur la conquête spatiale en
quoi en quoi ça consiste
alors les récrés artistes à la base un
artiste à laval à photographier ces
artistes plastiques danse et dans sa vie
personnelle qui s'appelle rodolphe
treader
et en fait c'est très simple si tu peux
lui appelle des conférences artistique
mais adressé aux enfants c'est plutôt
pour un public de primaires cp cm2 à la
base c'était surtout sur l'art plastique
et il a il s'est dit qu'il allait
essayer d'ensérune sur le sur la
conquête de l'espace donc c'est la
présentation de la conquête de l'espace
mais accessible aux jeunes d'accord
autres animations donc dimanche une
conférence à 16h45 co-animée par des
fans de la saga pour expliquer le
parcours en fait le cheminement de
création des films par georges le casque
il est fortement conseillé de réserver
pour assister aux conférences au numéro
qui s'affiche sur notre petite maquette
d'un petit agenda qu'on vous avez fait
pour présenter l'événement exactement et
finalement yoann cette exposition elle
est destinée acquis aux fans de la saga
aux amateurs de star wars alors plutôt
justement comme toutes nos expositions
c'est plutôt pour les pour les curieux
on va dire en un grand public de famille
et si les personnes qui connaissent peut
être pas beaucoup star wars ce qu'ont vu
que un ou deux films et et qui justement
ont envie d'en savoir plus si on a envie
de venir découvrir un petit peu creusé
un peu dans l'univers s'amuser un petit
peu aussi parce qu'on a des boussoles
interactive où quelques petits modules
accessibles au public donc c'est
vraiment pour ça ça s'adresse plus au
contraire aux curieux aux amateurs à
ceux qui ne connaissent pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup et qui voudraient venir venir
rêver un petit peu avant leur est
justement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler d'un petit truc original dans
l'exposition est ce qu'il ya une
maquette géante une navette géante un
vaisseau spatial qui vaut le détour ou
autre chose ben j'ai justement le leur à
dire là on a beaucoup de shoots et tout
est vraiment très intéressant et la lame
à dire le clou un peu l'exposition c'est
une création d'ailleurs vous en avez une
affiche un peu derrière moi là d'un
article de jean vos doc qui a créé
spécifiquement pour l'exposition une
réplique du tie fighters le vaisseau de
dark vador qu'à l'échelle 1/2 donc être
il est quand même très grand et
exclusivement en carton c'est vraiment
plus du carton de récup il ya pas de
bois ya pas de métal à 2 y a pas de
triche et ben voilà il l'a fait
spécifiquement pour l'exposition
d'accord et peut-être une petite d'art
action pour finir pour le futur sur
voisins le bretonneux vous pensé à
d'autres expositions danses est-il par
exemple sur le seigneur des anneaux
harry potter des côtes d autres
classiques de la pop culture alors on
n'a pas encore d'idée on n'a pas encore
l'idée pour les prochaines mois à titre
personnel j'aimerais beaucoup du couple
pop culture c'est vraiment très très
intéressant je trouve un à exploiter
donc we are harry potter ce serait bien
sûr le cinéma on s'est déjà dit sur
l'histoire du journalisme aussi fin on a
plein d'idées comme ça qui foisonnent
mais on sait pas encore du toit arrêté
sur sur ce que sur ce que ça pourrait
être en 2022 ou les années d'après en
tout cas on a hâte de voir ce que vous
nous préparez mais pour l'instant ce
sera l'exposition voisin contre attaque
donc qui est ouverte tous les jours sauf
le lundi du 27 novembre au 19 décembre
merci beaucoup il y aura une chez lindt
d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous bixente vous avez lancé
quelques inspirations peut-être pour les
pour les prochaines années c'est quoi
votre personnage préféré dans star wars
bus comme ça un petit bonhomme vert qui
parle à l'envers et qui parle qui parle
bizarrement être verte maître yoda que
j'aime beaucoup aussi alors une autre
une autre exposition à présent à bixente
dans un tout autre registre du côté de
jouy en josas yvelines jusqu'au 27 mars
s'étoffe et littérature est à découvrir
au musée de la toile de jouy cette
exposition présente les différentes
oeuvres littéraires qui ont inspiré les
arts décoratifs notamment le textile
reportage
[Musique]
des toiles de jouy ou des indiennes une
quarantaine de toiles à personnages sont
exposés ici au musée de la toile de jouy
à jouer en josas étoffes et littérature
décrit les liens entre les ouvrages et
ses tissus imprimés très populaire au
18ème 19ème siècle il était utilisé pour
l'ameublement principalement pour la
chambre qui nous permettent donc de
rêver de se souvenir n'a pas de
télévision n'a pas bradé au comment
est-ce qu'on se souvient de ce qu'on a
lu de ce qu'on a vu au théâtre ce qu'on
a entendu à l'opéra on va avoir des
toiles littéraire
e
cette exposition permet de comprendre
une société fasciné par l'ailleurs
l'amour ou encore l' aventure ce sont
d'ailleurs ces six désir qui divise
l'exposition des grands navigateurs
comme cook ou encore de bougainville
vous apporter cet esprit de découverte
dans les toiles on va retrouver
énormément de motifs comme l'a par
exemple un cocotier ou d'autres
civilisations comme ici les aztèques des
statuts des cactus ses toiles permettre
aussi de comprendre quelles étaient les
grands ouvrages qui plaisait à une
époque et qui pour nous aujourd'hui non
plus d'impact comme nina ou la folle par
amour mais d'autres oeuvres sont encore
très populaires exemple les fables de la
fontaine un oiseau sur un arbre et un
animal à quatre pattes en dessous le
corbeau et le renard la manufacture au
barcamp semble être à l'origine de ce
courant en france ses toiles sont
imprimés sur une plaque de cuivre très
rarement elles peuvent être imprimés
également la planche de bois
voilà pour cette exposition à jouy en
josas si on va terminer cette émission
bixente avec d'autres rendez-vous en
bref dans le week end un choc déjà
sportif très attendu mais le duel entre
deux des trois clubs de football
l'illinois toujours en lice en coupe de
france dans ce huitième tour ce week-end
versailles reçoit poissy dans son stade
mont boron de 7500 places un choc entre
deux clubs de nationale 2 même si
versailles et me placer au classement
ils s'étaient déjà neutralisé pour la 4e
journée un partout en début de saison et
puis qui sait un la magie de la coupe
grey gorille vous avez un petit
pronostic à nous et j'ai mauvais je suis
mauvais pronostic dans le si on parlait
sport j'avais 10 points 6 aux tirs au
but ils sont le tir au but bah je vais
dire aller versailles 2 1 pour pour
faire la contrebande ans de ce que vous
avez dit donc ça sera à 13h30 ce
dimanche 28 novembre au stade mont boron
tarif fixé à 10 euros et gratuit pour
les moins de 12 ans petit clin d'oeil
aussi à chatou qui à la même heure
défiera un autre club en coupe de france
c'est si chartres est un club entraîné
en plus par jean pierre papin alors
comme chaque semaine nous donne les
idées de sorties pour ce week end on se
projette aussi au week end après 4 et 5
décembre un humoriste avoir à maurepas
oui jean luc lemoine que l'on connaît
aussi comme animateur au chroniqueur
sera à l'espace albert camus pour son
nouveau spectacle brut il le décrit
comme un spectacle sans tabou sans
filtre voici un petit extrait c'est
comme essayer de faire un mikado et des
cocaïnomanes
le secret pour occuper les enfants c'est
le cache cache il adore ça les enfants
ils vont se cacher toi tu comptes
jusqu'à 50 et après tu les cherche pas
rendez vous donc samedi 4 décembre à
20h30 espace albert camus à maurepas
informations et réservations sur le site
de la salle ou au numéro qui s'affiche
dans votre agenda sur l'écran prix du
spectacle fixé avec un homo enfin un
rendez vous celui d'avoir que jean luc
lemoine voulait réapparaître à l'écran
voilà il voulait je voulais faire cette
petite promotion on termine avec un
rendez vous solidaire à noter en chaque
chaque fin d'année dans son agenda et ça
se déroule le week-end prochain jz c'est
le lendemain justement du spectacle de
jean luc lemoine pour vous décrasser
relâché on va dire vos abdominaux après
une soirée de rire qui rompt une des
abdos qui seront bien servis grâce à
notre humoriste vous pourrez prendre le
départ d'une randonnée au profit du
téléthon c'est du côté de saint germain
les deux itinéraires sont prévus le
premier plutôt sportif avec un départ
sous les coups de 8 heures 8 heures 30
pour une marche de 29 km le second on va
dire un peu plus pépère mais quand même
puisque c'est 13 km à 13 heures les
départs sont donnés donc à la piscine de
saint-germain-en-laye pour participer
c'est un don de nîmes au minimum 15
euros au téléthon de quoi allier l'utile
à l'agréable et une journée quand même
bien sportif grégory un peu importe le
départ que vous prendrez l'arrivée est
calculée souvent sur les côtes 17h 17h30
le téléthon en 2021 ce marathon en
faveur de la recherche pour les maladies
génétiques rares c'est les 3 et 4
décembre beaucoup de communes yvelinois
sont chaque année engagé mobilisés
notamment à villepreux aura l'occasion
de présenter justement le programme à
villepreux avec notre invité la semaine
prochaine merci bixente onze jeunes
justement rendez vous vendredi prochain
d'ici là prenez soin de vous ainsi
grégory et prenez soin de vos également
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission a le
7-8 week-end qui touche à sa fin on se
retrouve bien sûr lundi pour le retour
du journal sur tv 78 très bon week-end à
tous
[Musique]